[Music]
you've heard the term farm to table how
about
fish farm to table many scientists and
chefs believe it's the future of food
due to a combination of factors
including overfishing in the oceans and
a global population that keeps rising
fish farms haven't always had the best
reputation
but as we found out that seems to be
changing
fast this is one of the few
totally recirculating aquaculture farms
in the world we met dr kevin maine
at the moat aquaculture research park in
sarasota florida
the park is 20 miles away from the ocean
but has sea water running through it
constantly recycled and reused 24 hours
a day
fish under quarantine is not for covent
reasons no
definitely not for covert reasons that
is when we first bring them in
from the wild we have to keep them by
themselves
and have to check them and make sure
they're healthy and put them through
some treatments
4.14 at this farm maine is
raising red drum snook and more
so these are what kind of fish almaco
jacks amico jacks
they look hungry yep yep they're hoping
we're going to give a good lunch
if i stuck my finger in there i wouldn't
lose it but it would hurt
you could lose the tip i would recommend
it
elmaco jack also known as long thin
yellowtail
have very sharp teeth and are also very
adaptable
maine originally found these fish about
100 miles out in the gulf of mexico
they've been raised to be the perfect
healthy breeders
we've got males and females in here and
at least
three to four times a week they will
reproduce in this tank
fertilized eggs rise to the surface and
are sent out via
tubes to a collecting tank before being
sent to a hatchery
then eventually your plate it's like a
fertility clinic
it is for fish for fish
farming fish isn't new 52
of fish consumed around the world come
from onshore or
offshore fish farms the first thing you
might think of is farm-raised
salmon the industry however has been
hampered by a history of bad practices
including overuse of antibiotics
overcrowded facilities releasing waste
into the environment and lacks
regulation fish farms
have faced opposition why do you believe
those protests are
misguided because they're based on
technology that has been
going through a change moving from
learning how to do it
to learning how to do it better which is
what maine is working on here
she says depending on the size of the
fish the water in these tanks could be
used
filtered and reused again in as little
as an hour
after it leaves the pools it's sent to
an outside filtration system
which eliminates any toxic nitrogen put
out by the fish
but keeps the nutrients from there the
water travels into this plant house
where it's used to grow a second crop in
this case purslane
that process also serves to clean the
water before it's returned to the fish
it seems development of these new
technologies
couldn't come at a more crucial time
it's critical that we provide
protein to feed the world and there is
no more sustainable protein
that's produced than through through
fish farming these plants
are being grown hydroponically
scientists like maine are getting
support from rising chefs around the
country
including steve phelps who has become an
outspoken proponent for healthy
farm-raised fish to watch how an
operation works where i can have my
protein
and have a salad on the same plate
exactly right now is
it's fascinating
if you recognize phelps it's because
he's one of the chefs we featured on the
dish
just last month i'm afraid of what's
happening out on our waters
the pollution in the water the quotas
for the fishermen they're all starting
to get
pollution is getting higher quota's
getting smaller and
they're going to stop fishing soon over
the last 60 years global demand for fish
meat has more than doubled
while global supply has dropped
according to maine and phelps
it doesn't have to be that way it feels
like for so long we were told to buy
wild that's not the case anymore no i
you know
the numbers are staggering of how much
we're overfishing and and what's great
for a restaurant
and a chef like me is we've got
consistency in
product like this they're fed the same
thing they're in the same environment
they're harvested at the same size so
when i go to
create a menu i can always guarantee
that i'll have a two pound fish on it or
whatever is necessary
for phelps and kevin mayne the key to
ensuring a future for farm-raised fish
is getting the right information out
there about the process
where the food comes from and what it
will take to make sure
it lasts one thing i've learned is that
we've got to communicate more with the
public
when people come here and they see how
it's actually operating
they're comfortable with it it's a fresh
product
it's local it's going right here to your
restaurants
and the chefs know the product the
grocery stores know it it's really
the wave of the future now one of the
issues here is that the
seafood they're giving to the fish on
the farms often comes from the ocean if
you're trying to avoid
overfishing in the oceans that's one
issue but these processes are constantly
evolving
so i think they're working on trying to
make that better listen i've had i've
had bad
uh farm-raised fish and and good
farm-raised fish have a bad wild caught
fish right and good
so it's just important to figure out so
you know where it comes does it change
the cost dramatically
it all depends it depends where it is
and what kind of fish it is and that's
just like
the wild stuff you know as long as it
tastes good
i'm all for it right good and good for
the environment good for the environment